what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
the falcon and the winter soldier
episode 3 could have been the best
episode yet
it's hard to tell because they're all
pretty dang good but this time we got
zemo in
action and action on the dance floor by
him
it's hard to really beat that scene
right there so this could be the best
episode but we also got sharon carter
and a lot of other action as well
but go ahead and comment down below what
you would rate this episode out of 10
and this is going to be my scene by
scene breakdown but first i have a
rather interesting theory
about sharon carter now me and my buddy
chris over at my other channel cosmic
culture be sure to subscribe if you
haven't we're talking about this theory
and we think it makes a lot of sense and
the theory is that sharon carter could
actually be the power broker and if
she's not the power broker herself she
is clearly
involved with the power broker in some
way shape or form
and the flag smashers now there are a
few main points that lead us to believe
this about sharon carter one is she is
in madripore she's living in the higher
end not the lower
end which they visit and she's clearly
made well of herself
she's clearly a respected person in
madripore and she clearly has some power
not to mention baron zemo states that he
has only heard of the power broker and
never
actually seen the person then when bucky
sam and zemo start talking to her about
the power broker and the flax smashers
and the super soldier serum she tells
them that they should stay away from
this
for their own safety already trying to
lead them away and not dig into what is
happening when they mention dr nagel to
sharon she automatically knew that dr
nagel worked for the power broker
she already knew that inside information
then when zemo killed dr nagel she said
what did you do she was in shock and she
was concerned which is weird because he
was creating the super soldier serum
something that should not be around
anymore so the fact that she is so
concerned is pretty pressing
then when they part ways she tells her
driver we have a big problem
actually a couple i'll tell you in the
car one of the problems as we know is dr
nagle is dead but why is that a problem
to sharon
and the other problem would be is that
sam bucky and zemo are trying to track
down and destroy the other super
soldiers so it's very clear that sharon
carter
is involved with the power broker and
the flag smashers in some way shape or
form
again she is clearly important in
magipore the higher end which is where
the power broker is
and where carly morgenthau the leader of
the flag smashers once resided
could sharon carter actually be the
power broker herself
or could she simply just be working for
the power broker let me state that i do
not believe that sharon carter is bad
however
she may believe what the flag smashers
stand for or she could simply be in some
sort of trouble
but let me know your thoughts about this
theory in the comments down below and
now let's start with the shot by shot
breakdown
now when we start off the first part of
the falcon in the winter soldier episode
3 we feel like we're kind of watching
one division because we are getting yet
another
commercial during the middle of the
episode one division was notorious for
having sometimes confusing commercials
and sometimes commercials that slapped
you right in the face with some big
easter eggs however this one seems
pretty upfront
at least on the surface it is telling us
about the grc who we were
introduced to last episode the global
repatriation council
reset restore rebuild now from this
episode and the last episode it's pretty
clear that the purpose of the grc is to
help people who were snapped and came
back
to adjust to this new world that
everybody is now living in
and in the commercial it says that they
help people navigate changes to
society laws and borders this brings us
back to what rhodey said to sam in the
very first episode
he talked about how the world kind of
fell apart during that five-year blip
period
countries that used to be allies and
friends with each other were no longer
allies borders were shot to some
countries and laws were changed
now how they help we're unsure yet they
haven't really told us all they've
really told us
is that they help provide resources it
is clear that they have some vaccines
and medicine as the flag smashers stole
some medicine and vaccines from them in
the second episode
now on the surface and due to this
commercial it does seem like they are a
legitimate company however
the very next scene that we get is of a
police van
rolling up in munich filled with a swat
team and the new captain america john
walker and right on the side you can see
grc so yes they are claiming to help
people and maybe they are but they're
also funding a militia
and we're already seeing how different
john walker's captain america is from
steve rogers captain america as he walks
out of the van he says
don't give him a second to delete shred
or breathe and when he finally does talk
to the man he
ends up assaulting him now this is the
man from the last episode
episode 2 who was helping out the flag
smashers he believes in their cause and
he helped them by giving them a place to
stay and hide
so that's why john walker and lamar
hoskins are there to interrogate this
person
to see if they know where carly
morgenthau is the leader of the
flagsmashers
and we kind of see john walker's ego
come out here the captain america title
is going to his head as he says
do you know who i am and then something
rather interesting happens to him
outside the music gets a little eerie
and john walker touches his forehead and
also the footage starts to get a little
bit blurry implying that he's in some
sort of pain
now what i do think could be happening
here is that john walker has received
some type of super soldier serum perhaps
a non-perfected version that could be
giving him some side effects
after all the original captain america
did have a super soldier serum so why
wouldn't the new one have one now they
can't manage to track down
carly so instead they decide to try and
track down sam and bucky believing that
they will lead them to her eventually
meanwhile bucky and sam are going to
visit zemo
zemo of course was the person who in
civil war was out to get
all of the remaining super soldiers he
wanted to kill them all and he also
wanted to separate the avengers
and he did so at the end of civil war
t'challa black panther rest in peace
stopped him from killing himself and
they threw him in jail after that
and that's where bucky and sam visit him
now when bucky first goes into zemo's
cell
zemo starts listing the code words to
activate the brainwashing
inside of bucky now of course bucky is
no longer brainwashed and the winter
soldier inside of him can no longer be
activated this is why
bucky was in wakanda after civil war
shuri and t'challa helped rid him of his
brainwashing and it was a success he's
no longer brainwashed and zima knows
that but he was testing to see how he
would react
bucky tells zemo that somebody recreated
the super soldier serum and zemo is
deeply concerned about this because
remember
his whole entire purpose before was to
set out and get rid of the super
soldiers
zemo realizes that bucky is coming to
him because he thinks hydra is behind it
and zima knows
a ton about hydra and he actually knows
where to start so
breaking him out of jail begins however
he does not tell falcon at first instead
he tells him that he thinks
zemo should be broken out of jail
something that sam finds clearly absurd
considering what he did to the avengers
and
considering the fact that he killed king
t'chaka father of t'challa black panther
and he also states that wakanda has
definitely not forgotten about that
which ties into the final scene of this
episode like we talked about in the
beginning of this video
now bucky tells falcon about his plan to
break zemo out of prison
starting with a prison riot that bucky
actually instigates he gives a tiny
little note to an inmate saying that the
person that he is playing chess with is
going to kill him so he needs to kill
him first
this starts a riot that leads to a
series of events of zemo escaping prison
in which as bucky is finishing his story
to falcon about how zemo could break out
zemo actually shows up zemo takes them
to a garage where his family has
collected many things over time
and he finds his iconic purple mask now
in the comics
zemo wore the mask so he could hide his
identity during world war
ii he would go on to be exposed to some
adhesive
x and the mask fused to his face however
in the mcu it's obviously a little bit
different now there was a theory that
the purple mask was inspired by thanos
however since the mask was in his garage
he clearly had this way before thanos
came into the picture
putting an end to that theory now zemo
took down the old winter soldier program
and he says that he has no intention on
leaving his work unfinished
and since he has some experience of
tracking them down he knows where to go
and that is
madrapore to visit a person named selby
and
more on her in just a bit they go to
magi report in zemo's private plane
because as it turns out he's rich
he's a baron his family was royalty
until his country was destroyed
which is ironically when he began to go
and try to take out
superheroes now on the plane we figure
out that zemo has actually stolen the
little book that bucky is using to keep
the names of the people that he wronged
however he is hiding it in his own book
titled das nine in der liebe which
translates to the no
in love this book is about relationships
and how to help them
very fitting considering the fact that
falcon and bucky's relationship is kind
of rocky to begin with
but thanks to sam we find out that that
book was actually steve rogers he had it
with him when he went under the ice
it seems like steve gave it to bucky
before he left which brings us to the
point that we saw steve give falcon the
shield but we didn't see anything else
after that
he probably talked to bucky after and we
don't know what they talked about
but perhaps we could get a little bit of
a flashback and see old man cap and
bucky talking at some future episode
zemo talks about super soldiers and
superheroes how people view them
as icons as symbols but the only problem
with that is is that people forget about
their flaws
and this actually applies to the current
new captain america john walker
he's put on this pedestal as the new
captain america and everybody seems to
love him however as
we have seen and are starting to see a
little bit more of he is deeply flawed
and it looks like he could even end up
becoming bad
and doing some major damage now before
the team gets to match
report zemo explains that they just
can't walk in as themselves and bucky is
going to have to become somebody that he
claimed was gone
the winter soldier and sam's character
is a character by the name of conrad
mack conrad mack as they say in the
falcon and the winter soldier's nickname
was the smiling tiger
this is because he was actually pretty
feral and kind of part man and part
tiger he had claws and orange skin
in the comics he stole the avengers as
quinjet and landed in madge report and
stayed there which is why falcon is
disguised as him now we see a photo of
him and that's clearly not the case in
the mcu and this photo is actually just
a picture of anthony mackie dressed up
as sam describes it
as a pimp and from here the show starts
to escalate rather quickly we enter
madge report a city with no laws a city
full of criminals
now as i've talked about in the past in
previous videos madrapore
is a big location in marvel comics it
has a huge connection to the mutants and
x-men and a very particular connection
with wolverine now although no mutants
were shown in the falcon in the winter
soldier episode 3
at least that we know of as zemo sam and
bucky go into magiport we do see a sign
that says princess bar this is a
location that wolverine often went to
in the comics so they are giving us
these tiny little easter eggs that
are connecting to the mutants and some
big x-men characters here
zemo takes them to the bronze monkey
which in the comics it's a pretty big
place that's often talked about and
visited
however in the comics it's kind of just
a simple bar rather in this tv show
it's a pretty big nightclub when they
walk in everybody recognizes bucky as
the winter soldier
and zemo made it very clear that they
cannot break character
sam being the smiling monkey has to take
a shot of what appears to be just the
insides of a snake
and bucky has to act like he is still
the winter soldier
under the control of zemo zemo commands
him to attack
and he does so but if you notice there
are people filming him
a lot of people and this is not going to
be good because remember bucky was
pardoned for everything that he did but
if these videos get out on the internet
which they most likely will because
everything does he is looking like he is
still the winter soldier and being
controlled by zemo this is going to be
bad
news in fact in the first episode we
learned that the therapy sessions that
bucky was taking were government
required to make sure he wasn't still
out there losing control going around
hurting people
so the fact that people are filming him
acting like he's the winter soldier is
not good news a character whose face is
yet to be revealed puts a hood a little
bit more over her head as she hears the
fact that
baron bucky and sam want to talk to
selby of course we learn a little bit
later that this is sharon carter and she
ends up saving them all
they eventually work their way to get a
meeting with selby now they changed
selby's character quite a bit from what
he
actually is in the comics he is a man in
the comics who has the ability to
communicate with computers and he is
actually a mutant
doesn't really seem like selby in the
episode has any of those powers or could
be a mutant it looks like marvel just
kind of used the same name
and she ends up dying so i don't think
she's that important however she does
tell us about the power broker and dr
nagle the power broker's name is dropped
several times throughout this episode
and we find out that the power broker
was having dr nagle create the super
soldier serum but things kind of went
wrong
just like things kind of go wrong when
talking to selby thanks to sam's cell
phone ringing but
don't worry sharon carter is there to
save the day now it seems like she is
the one that kills
selby but in the street when she learns
about why they're there she says that
explains why you're here and why selby
is dead so perhaps somebody else was
behind that but i'm still going to say
i'm about
70 sure it was sharon who shot her now
we learned that sharon
has been on the run since civil war
getting captain america shield for steve
rogers and getting falcon his wings in
order to help bucky
she had to go to madrapore to get off
the grid and it looks like she's made a
pretty good living for herself as
a real hustler as she calls herself she
has real authentic artwork from monet
van gogh stealing them from the actual
museums where they sit replacing them
with fakes and then she sells them to
her clients
sharon is kind of deflated after the
events of civil war and avengers
infinity war and in-game talking about
how
the hero deal is kind of hypocrisy sam
also questions this because he questions
him giving up the shield later on
stating that he should have destroyed it
they tell her they're looking for dr
nagel and sharon automatically knows
that he works for the power broker
again i talked about my conspiracy
behind sharon carter in the beginning i
think she could actually be the power
broker herself or work directly for the
power broker whatever it is in the end i
do think
she will be good she goes to find more
information and tells everybody not to
get into trouble but everybody
is in trouble because zemo busted out
the sickest dance moves ever
and nobody stands a chance against him
usher or bruno mars could walk into the
building
and zema would put them to shame sharon
says she tracked down nagel if she
didn't already know where she was and
they go to the shipyard where you can
see the magipore flag
on one of the containers side note and
something interesting here is that she
actually
gives them communication devices to put
into their ears you'll often notice in
marvel movies everybody communicates
with each other but they don't really
ever show how
now we can obviously assume that
everybody has communication devices in
their ears at all times but in avengers
in-game where a ton of people came back
to life
suddenly when they could all magically
speak to one another without having
communication devices it's nice to
actually see this happen
here we meet dr nagel dr nego worked for
hydra and when hydra fell he was brought
in by the cia
there he did experiments on isaiah
bradley who we met in the last episode
he talked about being in jail and having
people experiment on him and it turns
out dr nagel was the person
experimenting on him
keep in mind the experiments were
probably more torturous than they were
scientific
but through isaiah's blood he was able
to perfect the serum and we find out he
made 20 vials which carly morgenthau and
the flag smashers stole from him now in
the comics dr nagle actually worked for
the us army and after captain america
super soldier serum during project
rebirth he was responsible for
recreating the serum he is the person
responsible for recruiting the 300
african-american soldiers who were used
as test
subjects for the serum in which only
isaiah bradley would survive
clearly they changed his story just a
little bit but he is still responsible
for experimenting on isaiah
ultimately zemo goes on to kill him and
a lot of people may think that zemo is
going rogue and bad but this
is what he set out to do in the super
soldiers and this doctor is creating
super soldier serum therefore
he killed him to zemo it's just a
process of eliminating all of the super
soldier serums and he didn't do anything
wrong in his eyes
now big big praise to sharon carter
slash emily vancam the actress who plays
her for the awesome action scenes that
we get
during this episode she completely kicks
butt along
with zemo rocking the purple mask taking
care of business and also bucky should
try out for the olympics for the javelin
throw because he
absolutely smashes somebody with a metal
pole from here bucky zemo and sam go
their separate ways from sharon carter
promising to get her pardon so she can
return to the states
from here we go to carly morgenthau and
a lot of people think that they see an
x-men sign
on this gate of the building to the grc
supply depot
i wish i could tell you it was i wish i
could even speculate on the fact that it
could be however
many people will recognize that this is
simply the european road sign for do not
enter sorry to disappoint from here we
learn a little bit more about carly
morgenthau
her life seemed to be considerably
better during the blip and when people
returned she got kicked out of wherever
she was
we learned that the dying woman that she
was visiting is mama dania and she was
dying of tuberculosis and in a later
scene we find out that she has indeed
died
it sounds like mama dania took in a lot
of refugees during the blip
made a home took care of everybody and
then when everybody came back they kind
of destroyed what she created
forcing carly to go to madrapore they
confirmed that they took the serum and
if you've been following my videos way
before the falcon and the winter soldier
even came out
i stated that the flax mashers were
probably super soldiers so this doesn't
come as a big surprise now of course
carly thinks that she is doing good and
she believes that she is trying to help
people
and it's curious that she knows that dr
nagel was killed in magipore perhaps
sharon carter is connected to her
somehow and called her
since sharon was kind of screwed over by
a bad government perhaps
she is kind of on the side of carly and
maybe she's helping her somehow
too many conspiracy theories for one
video i'm sure i'll do about 10 more on
what i think is going to happen
however carly even though she thinks she
is doing good steps up her terrorist
game by killing at least six men in an
upcoming scene
stating that that's the only language
that these people know so her group just
jumped it up
a bunch of different notches and a lot
of people are going to start to come for
them now
sam and bucky talk about the shield and
what it means and sam questions whether
he should have gave it up or not
stating that he should have destroyed it
because a lot of people's lives were
affected or destroyed because of that
shield like isaiah bradley being tested
and experimented on
by the us military and hydra scientists
however bucky says that it means a lot
of things to a lot of people
and can mean a lot of good so before sam
steals it and destroys it
bucky's going to steal it and says we
need a new captain america
one that isn't walker zemo bucky and sam
gotariga where zemo talks about visiting
the memorial of sokovia sokovia is where
zemo is from
and where his family died it's also
where pedro and wanda maximoff the
scarlet witch are from as well
and we know from the trailers that zemo
actually does go and visit the memorial
bucky feels like he's being followed so
he says that he's going to take a walk
here he finds the wakandan kimoyo beads
and eventually runs into ao she says
that she's there for zemo and this goes
back to what sam said in the beginning
of the episode
stating how dangerous zemo was stating
how he killed king t'chaka in captain
america civil war the current king of
black panther before t'challa and he
asked bucky do you think that wakanda
forgot about that
no they haven't and the fact that eyo is
here proves that no
they have not but it does look like we
are going to see some more wakandans
show up and possibly take a trip to
wakanda in a future episode of the
falcon in the winter soldier so let me
know what you thought of episode 3 let
me know what you rated it
in the comments down below i personally
think that each episode has gotten
better than the last and it's hard to
think that we're already halfway
done with the series but luckily these
episodes are a little bit longer than
one division so
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell for future videos
about the falcon in the winter soldier
and other marvel projects as well don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
me